hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain a 2022 American
thriller movie called shattered which
follows a Young Rich entrepreneur who
randomly meets a beautiful woman however
she's not as Charming As It Seems
Chris a young entrepreneur whose company
specializes in home security is doing
his morning routine in his house in
Montana
he currently lives alone as his marriage
is on the verge of divorce suddenly his
wife Jamie calls him to remind him to
sign the divorce paper Chris seems
unwilling to let her go but it's already
too late even after he reveals that he's
going to sell the company she makes it
clear that she's moving on because Chris
has been too focused on his company all
this time not prioritizing her and their
daughter that night Chris goes to a
nearby grocery store to buy an ice cream
unexpectedly he comes across a drenched
woman in a yellow jacket who asks him
for guidance in buying wine
she later introduces herself as Sky
outside the store sky is approached by
Chris and he offers her a ride home
which she agrees to a few moments later
they eventually arrive at a motel
Skye claims that she lives with a
roommate named Lisa and they both just
had a big fight which is the main reason
she ran away Chris offers her to stay in
his house for a night but Skye initially
refuses and gets out of the car however
Sky seems hesitating to enter the room
so Chris drives his car in Reverse
asking if she changes her mind she
finally accepts the offer and they both
go to Chris's Place upon arrival they
both begin to get to know each other
while drinking the wine they bought in
the store Chris tells sky that he was an
ex-mit and he's going to retire early
because Google Play offered him a huge
amount of money for his Watchdog home
security app meanwhile the young woman
claims that she used to work as a model
in LA but she quitted because she hated
being a living mannequin and now she
works in a bar afterwards Chris takes
Sky to his wine cellar where he gives
her the most expensive wine as a gift as
it's getting late Sky decides to sleep
there and they both have a good night
together
the next day Sky wakes up early and
decides to return to the motel alone
turns out that they didn't fight and
Lisa is very worried about her it's also
revealed that the motel belongs to Lisa
and Skye just lives there for free the
women argue and it seems that sky is
quite offended with Lisa's statements on
the other hand Chris feels guilty for
sleeping with another woman but at the
same time gets excited with the new
woman he met therefore he decides to
meet Skye again in her working place
after work they go for a walk where Skye
confesses that she never had a family
and his childhood was a nightmare not
long after they encounter a man who's
trying to break into Chris's car Chris
tries to negotiate but Skye aggressively
throws her bottle towards the punk
causing him to get furious and start
smashing Chris's leg with the iron bar
because of that Chris's leg is severely
injured forcing him to sit on a
wheelchair to repay his kindness Skye
offers to take care of him until he's
able to walk again of course Chris can't
deny the offer as he begins to fall in
love with her he also wants her to move
into his house thus he gives her the
secret code to access the house which is
fully secured with locks shortly after
Sky appears at the motel in a hurry and
immediately packs her things up Lisa
urges her not to leave because she loves
loves her but Skye manages to convince
her
she then returns to Chris's place where
they both begin to get more intimate the
following day Ronald the landlord of the
motel knocks on Lisa's door to collect
rent but to no avail he then breaks into
the room only to find Lisa's dead body
inside the bathtub soon the police
arrived to the crime scene and concludes
that it's a suicide but Ronald doesn't
seem to believe it furthermore the agent
tells him that they couldn't find any
records about sky and her identity in
their databases on the other hand Chris
talks to Jaime again via video call to
discuss their divorce and to cheer him
up the wife decides to bring their
daughter Willow on her next visit to
pick up the paperworks while sky is
taking a bath Chris accidentally finds a
picture of Skye and Lisa she realizes
that it immediately confronts him she
doesn't get mad at him at all instead
she throws her towel towards him and you
know the rest in the morning Chris wakes
up but cannot find his phone on the
table when looking for it he
accidentally learns about Lisa's death
on TV which eventually makes him a bit
vicious about his new girlfriend he even
gets more confused when he sees Lisa
returns home with a bucket of fried
chicken and eats them like crazy not to
mention that she was an ex-model Chris
then informs her about Lisa's death but
Skye doesn't seem to care at all she
even blatantly admits that she's the
perpetrator surprisingly she confesses
that she deliberately chose to live with
her in the past two months so that she
could observe Chris's activities using
her telescope from a very strategic
location meaning that their first
meeting at the grocery store was not
accidental feeling betrayed Chris gets
angry and tells her to get out but he
can't do much as the house is now in her
control with Chris's phone and her
possession she ties him up in his
wheelchair and admits that she only
wants his money since Chris is unwilling
to reveal her bank account's password
Sky tortures him by drilling through his
injured leg
meanwhile Ronald is cleaning up Lisa's
room when he accidentally discovers the
telescope he takes a look at it and
finds out that it's directed to Chris's
house where sky is doing her actions
back at the house Skye successfully
transfers all Chris's money to her bank
account the next day she kindly forces
Chris to liquidate all his stock to fun
Sky's new company skyco when she tries
to untie him so that he can make the
call to the Brokers Chris attempts to
choke her but Skye manages to stab him
in the shoulder she then threatens to
hurt his wife and daughter if he still
doesn't want to cooperate moments later
kiju the guy who injured Chris's leg
appears at the house turns out that he's
invited by Sky who intends to sell
Chris's wine and art collections to him
while Skye is away Ronald sneaks into
the house through the window before
helping Chris to Break Free the old man
asks him for a rescue fee so Chris gives
him a Picasso artwork that is worth
seven million dollar after that he helps
him get the tape off his wrist just
before they can escape Sky shows up and
blocks all the exit doors and windows
Ronald grabs a knife and tries to escape
until he's cornered left with no option
he tries his luck to kill the psychopath
however she is equipped with a katana
and manages to defeat the old man easily
meanwhile Chris uses this opportunity to
flee with his motorbike but he
eventually falls off the bike
he's then saved by a man named Sebastian
unfortunately instead of going to the
police station this guy drives him back
to his house and they reunite with Skye
turns out that Sebastian is Skye's
stepfather who trained her to become a
thief
still that night Chris confesses that he
loves her and that she doesn't need to
do this because he would have given all
the Glamorous Life to her however Skye
does not buy it and figures out that
Chris still has a lot of money inside a
safe deposit box in American Bank
realizing that they need a thumbprint to
enter the Vault Sebastian immediately
cuts his finger off in the Morning Jaime
and Willow arrive at Chris's place the
wife realizes that something is odd but
it's already too late as Sky manages to
find Willow she then locks the whole
family inside a storeroom afterwards
Skye and Sebastian depart to the bank
upon arrival they are welcomed by the
bank's officer and with Chris's thumb
they successfully passed the biometric
authorization process unfortunately when
they open the vault it turns out that
all the money was transferred by Jaime
to another place they immediately drive
back to the house
Chris eventually realizes that there's a
vent inside the room so he asks Willow
to crawl out of the room to unlock the
door from outside just after Willow
inputs the passcode the psychopath
couple arrive at the house to kill Chris
they searched the whole house until
Sebastian finds Chris and beats him up
when Skye is holding the gunpoint at
Chris Sebastian keeps urging him to
shoot Chris causing her to lose control
and end up shooting Sebastian instead
Chris uses this opportunity to retrieve
his phone and escape to the other room
he turns off all the light and
deliberately makes some noises to
distract her as sky is getting closer to
him Chris appears from behind stabbing
the psychopath but she fights back not
long after Jaime also shows up to a
sister husband however they both are no
match to Skye when the couple are
cornered suddenly Skye is shot from
behind surprisingly it's Willow who
fires the gun
shortly after the police finally arrive
at the house in her last breath Skye
reveals to Chris that her real name is
Margaret
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching